The little prince is sitting
on his little planet,
and he's watching
the planets go by.
And so suddenly, he's
seeing three of them.
One, two, three.
And he wonders, hmm, what
would the center of mass
of these three planets be?
So let's calculate it.
We have one planet
here that's three times
the mass of this guy.
And then this one
has half of m1.
And I've written this
up there already.
And the center of
mass, when we want
to determine its coordinate--
it is a coordinate
that depends on this
coordinate system,
and this origin
here-- then we need
to have the total
mass of the system,
because it's a
mass-weighted coordinate.
And so the total mass
is going to be 4.5 m1.
And if we want to
calculate this position
function of the
center of mass, Rcm,
that is the mass weight here.
And then we need the
sum of all of our masses
times our distances.
We're going to sum here
over j from 1 to n.
And what that means is
we need to now write out
the sum for our three planets.
And we need to give
this a radius here,
so the r1 would be
going from here to here.
r2 goes from here to there.
And r3 from here to here.
You need to write them
out in the i hat direction
and in the j hat direction.
Let's add that here.
And then sum it all up
and calculate our r.
So let's write this out.
We have m1, and we're
going to have 35 and 10.
35 i hat plus 10 j hat plus m2.
It's going to be 5 and 20.
5 and 20.
And then m3, we have 40 and 30.
And what we can do--
oh, and of course that
has to be divided
by my system mass.
And what we can do is
we can concentrate first
on the x component, and
then on the y component.
Maybe we'll just continue here.
So we're going to have-- and
we can plug it in all the m's.
We'll do it for the
x component first.
We're going to have m1, and
then we have 35 i hat plus here
we're going to have 1/2 m2.
That is 3m1 5 plus-- and
for m3, we have 0.5 m1 40.
that's in the i hat direction.
And we'll have to divide
that over our system mass.
And then we do the same
for the y component.
So m1, 10 plus 3. m1,
20 plus 0.5 m1 30 j hat.
And again, we have to divide
this over our system mass.
So this boils down to-- hang on.
Let me redo this again.
Let me actually look
at the answer first.
What do I have here?
70 and 85, OK.
So this boils to m1
over the system mass.
And we have 70 in the i hat
plus 85 in the j hat direction.
So the 70 comes from this
term, the 80 comes from this.
And I put it back together, and
now we need to plug in this one
here.
And so we will get in the end
of that Rcm equals m over 4.5 m.
So the m goes away, and we
have a factor of 1/4.5 here.
We'll divide this
through, and we're
going to have 15.5 in the
i hat direction, and 18.9
in the j hat direction.
All right, so let's see where
this fits on our graph here.
So 15 in the i hat
is somewhere here.
And 19 is almost
20, so it's going
to be here, so about there.
So this is my Rcm,
and this here is
my center of mass of the system
of these three little planets.
Of course, we used approximate
math here for all the planets.
But if we look at
the real numbers,
imagine that this
would be Earth,
and it has one Earth mass.
And if this were Saturn,
it would have something
like 318 Earth masses.
And if this is Pluto, it would
have 0.0025 Earth masses.
You will see that Saturn
really holds all the weight.
And if we were to do this
calculation with these numbers
here, then our Rcm would-- and
keeping this coordinate system
in the arrangement
of the planets,
then it would go right
into-- if here's the center,
it would go right next to
the center right over here,
because Saturn just weighs so,
so, so much more than Pluto
and Earth together.